Wow
where am i I don't know where I am it's
your place this isn't my place this is
Marc else's place but I'm not sitting
with Marc Ellis he's gonna be in there a
little bit later this is Kristian
harloff or schmoes no we're gonna be
talking about our top 10 most wanted
directors for a Star Wars movie this is
a dream list and maybe even a possible
looks like things that might tangibly
happen if you guys don't know who the
schmoes know is this is one of them the
other one's coming in later better
welcome one the better-looking one
maybe that's it's up for debate it's
true all right so let's get right
started with number 10 number 10 for me
this is one that you guys may or may not
know if you're not die-hard Star Wars
fan that's Dave Filoni who Dave Filoni
is a guy who was basically the executive
producer of the Clone Wars and now is
the executive brucer and creator of Star
Wars rebels now you talk about a guy
that knows the Star Wars universe it's
this guy when we were at Star Wars
Celebration every panel that you went to
whether it was gareth edwards talking
about the new movies or it was Leland
Chi as part of the story group they all
talked about how crucial Dave Filoni was
this guy knows the universe works hand
to hand with Simon Kinberg and also a
big film guy yeah now what do you think
about him coming from animation going
directly into live-action because that
is a hard transition we've seen people
do it successfully in the past what do
you think he would bring to it that's a
good call I mean listen I don't know
what the live-action element for Dylan
it would look like I really don't but
for me what I'm basing it on is how he
directs story and so far what he's done
in the story and the character overall
he knows Star Wars he is Star Wars he
holds so much I mean George Lucas
trained him and regardless of what
you're gonna says all that that might be
a negative no not in story not in story
not a story and as far as the way the
development of Star Wars this you think
George Lucas was Yoda man when it come
to the Star Wars story and felonious it
really well so that's why I would like
to see him there you know I agree with
you I really think I like rebels so far
everything I've seen of it I haven't
seen every episode of season 1 but I've
seen the first half of season 1 does he
have much involvement on Clone Wars oh
yeah yeah oh yeah
I like everything I've seen in Clone
Wars also the first movie wasn't so
great but I think even he they flung
himself has acknowledged that the first
gun wasn't that great yeah he able
that's that's another reason I like him
for what he does I so kitano did not go
over well in that movie right no and he
listened to the fans as well George when
George are well put him in more you know
like not following flan he developed her
more now she's one of the most beloved
and that's exactly why because he's able
to take his mistakes and build off right
and I think you're right I would like to
see what he could do the Star Wars movie
if he was given the chance alright let's
get going with this list we're gonna
move into number 9 at number 9 we have
Alex Garland now you may have seen a
film called ex machina we both like that
he liked a little more than I did he
really understands sci-fi and that was
one of the the best parts of that movie
it had a very brainy aspect of sci-fi it
was smart there was more ideas than
special effects and even though there's
always a lot of special effects in Star
Wars movies the parts about Star Wars
that are most resonate with most people
are the ideas you know the force what is
the force it binds us all together that
all these ideas that surround the galaxy
of Star Wars so I could see him doing a
really good Star Wars movie I totally
agree with you there I think that what
Alex Garland brings to the table when I
saw ex machina actually reminded me a
lot of thx 1138 yeah there were a lot of
elements to that and also who did he
work with domhnall gleeson and Oscar
Isaac right so so whether or not it's
this Boba Fett supposed a movie that's
gonna happen or something completely
different maybe we don't know they're
not gonna spin off maybe Poe dameron's
character into another movie or domhnall
gleeson we still don't know who the hell
he's playing right so there's a lot that
he could do and I agree with you 100%
where the Star Wars at its best
you think about all the the parallels
that it has and in the philosophies and
I think Alex Garland did that well in ex
machina and what is that up-and-coming
director that I believe is about to do
something special and why not in the
Star Wars universe
well for number eight had to bring in
the better-looking one yes I didn't want
to tell Christian to his face up is that
other guy yeah at number 8 we have
Christopher Nolan now Christopher
Nolan's a guy they look he made
interstellar not everybody who loved it
loved it loved it like they hoped they
would but it was a fantastic feat in
filmmaking Plus this guy knows a little
bit about humming a popular franchise
and spinning it into gold
yeah one of the reasons I would love to
see Christopher Nolan do a Star Wars
movie is not just because he's made good
movies I mean a lot of people weren't
big fans of interstellar but some people
loved it but it's hard to find a movie
of his that really is terrible the fact
remains though that with interstellar he
used so much practical effects so much
practical imagery and those scenes in
space looked real there wasn't a single
moment in interstellar where I was like
that's a computer that's that's fake
even the scenes like where he was in the
tesseract at the end everything looked
had this tangible realism to it that I
think would be perfect for a Star Wars
movie and he's obviously a fan because
he has stated that Episode four a new
hope was the first film he saw that
really inspired him and got him to want
to make films as a kid that's right and
besides interstellar being a gorgeous
film to look at it also is very
inventive with some of the ideas that it
puts forth as was the dream one
inception inception II will just call
that movie blond and even in Inception
he shows some things that we've never
seen before plus I mean again the guy
brought back Batman from nothing so
imagine what he could do with Star Wars
a franchise it already seems to have its
footing back under him he's also a
superstar director whereas Kristian
pointed out sometimes if you're making a
film in the Star Wars universe that
doesn't it that the lore isn't as well
known like an Old Republic film or
something like that
he alone puts butts in the seat so if
you hear Christopher Nolan's attach to
the Stars project it'll get people
excited I agree with you and one of the
things that Nolan focuses the most on in
his movies is never actually the visuals
but the characters even in with
interstellar say what you want about it
the focus in that movie was 100% on the
characters the father/daughter
relationship even in Inception it was
always something was going on in the
back of the action that was important to
these characters and the reason Batman
was so great again is because they
focused on the villains they focused on
the heroes and they made these real
tangible likable people that that felt
like they existed
and what do we love about Star Wars the
characters most speaking of Inception
let's get Christian back from his nap
good riddance okay so moving on to
number seven
Alfonso Khurana this gentleman has made
some pretty good big films and a really
good small film which had big moments
like children of men that was a smaller
movie by most people's standards but it
had incredible moments that he made look
so much bigger because of his one take
direction
a lot of Harry Potter fans as you
mentioned earlier we were talking don't
really like the third Harry Potter film
I did though and I thought it was a
really well directed movie and of course
gravity a movie that took place almost
entirely in space so the guy understands
how to make space look good and I think
he could really do that with a Star Wars
movie the third Harry Potter and I know
I know I know but I love it it's
actually one of my favorites of the
series I loved what Quran did it I
actually liked one of the smaller films
e tu mama tambien which I think that
what he does so well is characters and
you're right in gravity he showed that
he's really good with visuals yeah and I
think that children remember is a blend
of both of those I think that that's
what you need in Star Wars is someone
that's gonna take these characters and
develop some brand new characters to
whether or not maybe we because what we
do know is we don't want to keep
spinning off into well there's a young
Han Solo movie there's Boba Fett we're
gonna get brand new characters
eventually and who better to develop
brand new characters in Alfonso Kuran
that's a good possibility to have that
guy furthering the Star Wars lore so I'm
all for well it's the good-looking guy
again and at number six we have a film
with the maker of the film that we both
loved last year and it felt a lot like
Star Wars that would be guardians of the
galaxy james gunn james gunn is a person
who basically made a Star Wars movie I
mean if you change the character names
and you had rocket and replace rocket
with Han and you made Groot Chewie
then you got Han and Chewie you got the
buddy relationship right there the big
tall guy who wanders around and does
things for the the smart-aleck I mean
that is Star Wars yeah I mean I'm not
sure that tape decks exist in the Star
Wars universe but if they do even find a
way to get that volume of his from the
70s and 80s in there look he made such a
fun movie such a fast paced film it was
great dialogue in Star Wars
unless we forget has a lot of humor in
it especially the original trilogy has
humor that works I think James Gunn is
one of those guys that can combine the
action and humor in a way that Star Wars
fans are gonna want to see for me
guardians of the galaxy was a movie that
I also understood that the humor and the
characters were more important than
amazing action sequences which we want
to see we want to see amazing action
sequences but we want to see amazing
action sequences with characters we care
about that we like that we actually want
to see do these things and James Gunn
writes great characters he writes great
dialogue and a Star Wars movie needs
that and I would love to see him do
maybe an anthology film or whatever else
Lucasfilm has up their sleeve I would
just love to see James Gunn involved
with that in some way well speaking of
characters doing things we want them to
see Chris and I both are really excited
we got to be on your channel for this
ten through six list of directors we
want to see in Star Wars and I was very
happy to have you guys here if you guys
don't know the schmoes know art you
probably do they run a great YouTube
channel movie reviews interviews they do
a podcast every Thursday
these guys are also really nice guys
they're my pals and I enjoy doing videos
with them so definitely check out their
channel for the remainder of this list
and give them a subscription if you'd
like to and thank you so much as always
for watching guys and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes studio was a lot like ours
that's a cool